she's in the battle dimension we have to
go in and get her back
Oh freeze be too kind to his tourists
we're gonna need everything you've got
to get Anna back
what this cosplay is way better than
mine try to kept the fake mustache no
you're right any ideas we need to start
another countdown one more could get us
all out of here
I think my name is Walter benezia for
months I was trapped in the evil Dynel
Rob's Dynel dimension a place where I
was duplicated dozens of times
eventually I managed to escape but now
die rob is sending his army to take me
back with the help of my friends he
fight them off and hope to ultimately
take down mr. rage dinosaur the more we
countdown the weaker he gets this is
top-5
[Music]
since the Super Mario games have become
so popular every new installment has
introduced new characters who either
help or hinder the Mario Brothers on
their quest to save the Mushroom Kingdom
some of these characters have developed
huge followings in their own right and
are fan favorites of millions of people
this cast of supporting players is
absolutely a massive reason why the
Mario games have endured for so long
whether you've gotten to play as them in
their own spin-off games or just enjoy
leaving others in the dust in a Mario
Kart race these characters have
contributed an important part to the
Nintendo legacy and it's time to wrap up
Mario May with our favorites these are
the top five Oh
[Music]
oh boy these are the top five best Super
Mario characters number five Rosalina
Rosalina is a fairly new addition to the
mario family she was first introduced in
Super Mario Galaxy she quickly became
some fans favorite Mario princess
including mine what makes this character
so great and compelling is her rich
backstory there was a literal storybook
telling all about her life and how she
became the mother of the Lumis and the
keeper of the comet observatory her
story is beautiful and tragic as a child
she meets a young luma who is lost and
can't find her mother the pair decide to
build a spaceship to search for Lumas
mother together they searched the galaxy
ultimately Rosalina's confronted with
the realization that she has been in
space so long her mother is likely dead
she then declares the Lumas are now her
family and children she goes back to her
home planet every 100 years to visit
there is a certain wisdom and calmness
in Rosalina she has obviously
experienced and learned from many
adventures out in the galaxy another
wonderful trait of hers is independence
she's not kidnapped or in distress it's
hard to even see her being shipped with
any of the other Mario characters
although I'm sure it's been done no need
to Google that overall Rosalina is a
complex character and one of the reasons
that I love Super Mario Galaxy so much
I'm very glad to see that Nintendo has
included her in many games since
come on imagination
[Music]
of course number four toad we can't have
a best Mario characters list without
this little guy he's been there from the
beginning and remained a very popular
part of many of the Mario games since if
there's one word to describe toad it's
helpful yes those are princesses and
another castle screams could be annoying
and even frustrating but don't shoot the
messenger man without toad to explain
things to us in games like Super Mario
64 it'd be much more difficult to
navigate our way through those massive
worlds or learn how to use some of our
environment to our advantage
toads accompanied the mario brothers in
animation with the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show The Adventures of Super Mario
Brothers 3 and even in the live-action
movie I guess while toad has
occasionally been a protagonist and a
few of Mario's adventures over the years
I think he really came into his own as a
playable character in the many Mario's
sports slash competition games I know a
lot of people who love using him in
tennis baseball Kart and much more all I
need is tote is a playable character in
the new Super Smash Brothers game and
he'll have reached an even higher level
although there are more deserving
Nintendo characters who should have been
in a smash game by now who Luigi I'm not
a duplicates wallet
looks pretty busy we gotta keep this
countdown going number three
Bowser Mario's main antagonist has been
tormenting him for over 30 years now
originally known as king koopa bowser is
constantly trying to take over Mushroom
Kingdom
his most consistent method of doing this
kidnapped Princess Peach fail kidnap
Princess Peach fail repeat fail repeat
fail repeat repeat repeat so it hasn't
worked out too well for him over these
three decades mostly due to our favorite
Italian plumbers or former plumbers
whatever point is Bowser may not be very
successful in his pursuit of fungus land
but he's a fun character that's been
explored in the dozens of other Mario
games
who doesn't love dominating as this
cupen despot and one of the Smash Bros
games once in a while even some of his
kids have become popular characters in
their own right I'm looking forward to
seeing how they use Bowser in the new
animated Mario movie coming out in the
near future it can't be any worse than
monkey
[Music]
number two Yoshi Yoshi is perhaps one of
the most beloved and recognizable
sidekicks in videogames the trusty and
adorable steed made his first appearance
in Super Mario World for the SNES from
his introduction Yoshi was a fan
favourite his loyalty
cuteness and pluck attracted many Yoshi
was first found on Yoshi island he is a
part of the Yoshi species Yoshi's have a
couple of special abilities most
noteworthy is their long tongues that
can grab items Yoshi can then turn that
item or enemy into a spotted egg this
egg has become a trademark of Yoshi's
character Yoshi's can come in many
different colors in some iterations of
the games each color has different
abilities or purposes the character of
Yoshi though is usually green with red
he has spawned many of his own games
including Yoshi's cookies and a couple
of Yoshi's Island games people just
can't seem to get enough of him
[Music]
no it's morphin time one more and the
number one best Super Mario character is
[Music]
Wario the perfect nemesis and reluctant
antihero Wario first appeared in Super
Mario Land 2 where he stole Mario's
castle Wario is often portrayed as
greedy and crude he is motivated by
riches and fame but he's also strong and
cunning mario and wario are perfect
foils off of each other they make great
rivals since they both have very
different objectives in their lives
Wario is jealous of Mario's fame and
tries relentlessly to achieve the same
he eventually resorts to creating a mini
games factory to make his fortune in the
Wario Ware series which I personally
enjoy Wario has appeared in many games
since his first inception and has even
spawned his own series people love to
see the dynamic personality of this
character explored through games I'm
sure we will see much more of him in the
future
[Music]
looks like the princess didn't need
saving after all the red Terminator
power wasn't made for Ayanna's energy
signature if she stays more for too long
and could kill her
[Music]
where
[Applause]
[Music]
you have to power down ion a quick write
power down
how did we get out of here there's your
answer
[Music]
so I think we can all agree that red
Terminator outfit looked way better on
me maybe I could borrow it sometime
yeah actually I'd like to try it
sometime - yeah keep that in mind
[Music]
you guys weird
[Applause]
[Music]
you
I hope you enjoyed your stay brain-dead
buffoons you know what they say about
the Dino dimension once you visit you
can never truly
[Music]
[Laughter]
you